would you rather let your coach or your  parents see your full internet history  I'm definitely my coach would you rather  have diarrhea at the altar on your  wedding day or get diarrhea during the  first lap of a race I think diarrhea  first half of the race I think people  would even notice would you rather be a  good racer with a bad reputation or a  bad racer with a good reputation  definitely amazing with a bad reputation  you could play another sport would you  rather play in the NFL or the NBA NBA  would you rather listen to the same song  for the rest of your life or never be  able to listen to the same song Twice  never yeah I'd prefer never being able  to listen to things would you rather  never eat sushi for the rest of your  life or only eat sushi for the rest of  your life  [Music]  I think my stomach wouldn't handle  always easy